Former president Donald Trump's Truth Social site,...
…has yet to generate any ad revenue.
Yeah, that's according to a new regulatory filing for the business,...
…the platform's parent company Trump Media and Technology Group,...
...is also losing money.
Truth Social is now hoping, that posting exclusive content and messages...
…from the former president could help attract users and book some ad sales.
CBS news tech reporter Dan Patterson joins us now for more on this.
Hey, Dan great to see you.
So, what are some of the factors,...
…playing into why Truth Social has not had any paid advertisers yet.
Well, as we know, in television and on social media,...
...one thing that advertisers love is an audience.
And look, it's really hard to sell ads,...
…if there are no users on a social media site.
And however you feel about the president's politics,...
...there's no users or very few users on Truth Social.
In fact, other right leaning social media sites like Parler and Gab,...
…far exceed the number of users on Truth…
…and those sites have a hard time attracting a user base.
Dan, this regulatory filing flagged former president Trump's previous record,...
…with running businesses noting,...
…that a number of those associated with him have gone bankrupt.
So, what could that mean for the future of this venture,...
…or at least the president's involvement in it.
Uh, well... look, if he is able to exclusively post here,...
...it could attract very hardcore users.